these days it seems just about everybody
or every business has an app and it
turns out it's really not that difficult
to produce one if you have the help of
software as a service the sponsors of
this segment patrick parker joins us to
talk more about this patrick thanks for
being here today
absolutely thanks for having me on it's
great to be enjoying some of the sunny
weather for a change in kentucky here oh
yeah you're coming to us from kentucky
and we have had some rain as well but
yeah we're enjoying sun most of the time
here we're talking about software and
specifically apps and these days do
most people expect every business to
have an app
absolutely without a doubt so the
biggest thing about having an app and
what consumer brands expect
is that with branding you're really
trying to deliver a consistent
experience across all of your customer
touch points and so in order to meet
customers where they are you need to
have an app because customers are always
on the go right your workforce is on the
go
they're actively moving around they need
to understand that they can still
interact and engage with your brand with
their company
and so it's just become an extension of
themselves when an app belongs on a
phone a phone belongs on a hand and a
hand gets the attention of the eyes so
without a doubt and that's one aspect of
what software as a service does who uses
your service
everybody whether you realize it or not
so software as a service is basically a
subscription and service delivery model
that focuses on delivering web-based
products so think scheduling think um
your video conferencing like we're doing
now for me to remote in
your crm crms your accounting softwares
all of that is provided through
cloud-based services so
whether you realize it or not you
probably use at least 10 of them in your
daily uh business life and you build the
software as a service
absolutely so not only do we just build
software as a service products which
makes up the majority of our clients but
we build custom software across the
board so we build everything from
smart device
software we build everything from web
and mobile apps we do a lot of different
things here but the core of it all is
custom software which is what we're
using to help businesses
grow their customer bases meet their
customers where they
are hanging out and ultimately drive
revenues and this is you say for all
businesses of any size because some
smaller ones might shy away when they
think about technology and cost
associated with it how much does this
mobile app development generally cost
yeah and so i think there's a big
misunderstanding around
the the cost right so with globalization
and increased competition within the
market
it's completely changed it's become a
lot more affordable than it used to be
uh and the biggest problem that i have
and we always get this question whenever
we're interviewing clients whenever
we're going through discovery calls they
always want to know what am i looking at
as a ballpark right and i think that's
the wrong mentality to go into it
because what you're really doing is
you're creating a new asset for your
business a digital asset in this regard
sometimes it's a community where you're
able to build loyalty and actually
interact and engage with them sometimes
it's in order to actually deliver a
service or a product so
there's a lot of different uses for
software in general but at the root of
it all it's very affordable at this
point in time and so if you understand
the customer lifetime value that you
have for each of your clients and you
can get really creative in terms of what
you're actually spending
uh to have a custom software product
built and that will help you understand
what return you can expect and new ways
that you can add value to all of your
customer base great stuff patrick parker
thanks for joining us from kentucky
today appreciate it absolutely thanks
for having me on and we want to thank
smg group for sponsoring this segment
for more information about software as a
service visit saas partners dot io